رغم انها لا تحمل درجه علميه رفيعه ولا
تملك ماضيا مليئا بالعمل والشقاء لبناء
عمل خاص تتربع على ثروه تقدر بنحو 21
مليارا و 900 مليون دولار وهي اغنى
الافراد في تشيلي وخامس اغنى امراه في
امريكا اللاتينيه و ثامن اغنى امراه في
العالم فما سر هذه الثروه ولدت اريس
فوتبول عام
1942 لم تكن تعلموا انها يوما ما قد تصبح
ملكه
لثروه كبرى عندما كانت في السابعه عشره من
عمرها التقت باندرويد
الذي كان ارمله يكبرها بخمسه عشر عاما
وتزوجته عندما كانت في العشرين من عمرها
وكان ذلك اهم منعطف في حياتها فهذا الزوج
الثري الذي اصبح لاحقا الرجل الاكثر ثراء
في تشيلي هو مؤسس مجموعه لوكسيك
الاقتصاديه التي تدير استثمارات عديده
وكبرى على مستوى العالم تاسست لوكسك في
خمسينيات القرن الماضي وبنيه عبر
الاستحواذ على الشركات الصغيره وبناء
استثمارات في المجالات المختلفه التي
تنقسم بدورها الى مجموعتين الاولى انتم
فكاستا في السيه التي تتحكم في عمليات
التعدين والسكك الحديديه والثانيه مجموعه
كوينكو المتخصصه في التمويل والتصنيع تعد
ان توفى كاستا بي ال سي احدى اهم الشركات
المتخصصه في قطاع التعديل ومنتجا اساسيا
للنحاس في جميع انحاء العالم كما تدير
شبكه واسعه من السكك الحديديه في شمال
تشيلي اما شركه كونينكو فتندرج تحتها
اعمال عديده مثل تصنيع منتجات نحاس والشحن
وصناعه المشروبات الروحيه خلال حياته طور
اند روني كوباروا امبراطوريته التجاريه
ونقل جزءا من عمله لابنائه ثم تنحى
للاستراحات بعد اصابته بمرض السرطان الذي
لم يمهله طويلا حيث توفي في عام 2005
تاركا ثروه تقدر بنحو اربعه مليارات
ومئتين مليون دولار
اكتسبت اريس ثروه كبيره بعد وفاه زوجها
الذي انجبت منه بنتين ماريا باولا وماريا
غابرييلا وابنهما جون بول الذي تولى رئاسه
كل من ان توفي كاستا وكوينكو كما ذهب جزء
كبير من الثروه لابنه من زوجته الاولى
اندرونيكو وجيرمو الذي توفي لاحقا بسرطان
الرئه نجاحتها عائلتهبونه في مواصله طريق
النجاح ونمت نجاحات الشركه بشكل كبير
فاصبحت المجموعه توسيطر على ثاني اكبر بنك
في تشيله واكبر مصنع بيره في العالم واكبر
مناجم النحاس في العالم واكبر شركه شحن في
العالم اضافه الى سلاسل للفنادق الفاخره
تملك ايرث فونت اليوم ثروه تقدر بواحد و20
مليارا 900 مليون دولار ليس لتصبح واحده
من الاسماء الكبيره في عالم المال
والاعمال فقط بل وايضا اما ومربيه في
عائله ناجحه تتشارك معها الانجازات في كل
خطوه
[موسيقى]